sadness because it's just
you know we didn't we didn't play as
well as a team as we wanted to and um
you know we could throw out all the
things that happened this season and
just heavy emotionally and you know now
that the series is done and we can
congratulate the boston celtics for
you know doing what they came to do you
know doing what they were supposed to do
just closing out very uh mature and
doing all the little things but uh yeah
just disappointment sadness but also
more importantly on the positive side
there's motivation and
you know it's just burning in my heart
right now
you know i know so many
people wanted to see us fail
at this juncture you know picked us as
contenders and
um
you know have so much to say at this
point so i'm just using using that as
fuel for the summer and coming into the
season starting from october um and and
just getting a good start as a team and
you know hopefully we don't run into any
barriers um
and we could just start fresh and uh you
know be realistic with our own
expectations uh and live with our team
results rather than
um you know be in the polarization of of
kind of the media scrum and having our
names be
dragged you know for a series that um
naturally happens in people's careers
you know
uh so it's definitely um exciting to
have this motivation
um going into the summertime now so
when you uh i mean you talked about
being quote the favorites you know
coming into this season do you consider
this
understanding everything that it went
through you know that
whatever the interruptions of the season
the injuries all of that do you consider
this underachieving considering what
your
a your your standard was but be all of
the things you had to go through
i think we just faced the facts that uh
you know it was just a heavy uh lift for
us throughout the whole entire season i
mean i was out
um kev was out james gets traded um
you know and that's it's not and i'm not
using those as reasons on why things
didn't go well probably just for this
series but it's just a combination of
things that happen throughout our year
that i think um you know naturally as a
human being you feel emotionally and um
you know it's hard to just turn the
switch on and just be like all right
we're a great team today and uh
you know what i mean like
you know you don't have a week to really
prepare guys are in and out of the
lineup and
there's just so much attention and and
so many things that get into our locker
room just
um
you know us not having a
probably a a team balance of of what
affects us and impacts us and how much
trust we have one another when things
get uncomfortable you know we just got
to be tested a little bit more and and
for me this is a point in my career
where i'm grateful for
you know this happening at this point
because now just the experience is there
and the lessons are there but
um yeah it's been a long season
you know i felt like
uh
in the middle of it there could have
been a
or a choice to end i want to say in the
middle of it but towards the end you
know january february march
just tough months for us to really find
that groove and i think we found it in
pockets but now going to the summer i
think you see
um what we need in order to be a great
team you know instead of it just being
individually about how great we are or
what we can accomplish with just a few
guys
kyrie there were moments in this series
for you and for the ball club why do you
think
the nets lost this series overall
uh
it just
i mean we could we could start with uh
you know just just us gelling as a team
more importantly during this time i've
said it you know for the last few games
you know down the stretch uh just being
able to be in spots that we're all
comfortable in
you know having a lineup out there that
um
you know can can match up well with them
uh you know stopping them from getting
offensive rebounds and and just being
uh
you know prepared in a way that uh we're
just thinking we're just playing on our
instincts you know there was a lot of
thinking going on out there and you
could tell
and um you know when that's happening
you're not playing with your instincts
and trust in the game you know
i don't want to say you turn into a
shell of yourself but it's just you're
not having the game that you want you're
not playing in the flowing rhythm and i
give credit to the celtics for for
making it tough on the defensive end but
the majority of it on on our end was um
you know just trying to find a balance
of who's out there with us so
you know just the little details again
that i always point to
uh we just couldn't control those so
line up and um you know just controlling
what we control just offensive rebounds
transition turnovers basketball
stuff kyrie do you think that this uh
season serves as a maybe a lesson for
what is required to go through 82 games
the amount of commitment that an entire
team or franchise needs to
have amongst each other and secondly do
you plan on pursuing an extension with
the brooklyn that's this summer
oh [ __ ]
oh man um
to answer your first question can you
ask your first question again just oh
for the a2 game season i apologize uh
yeah no i just think it it's important
when um
you know
you can start as a team in october
and and just
really build
a relationships outside of the game so
when you're on the floor it's just
it becomes a trusting trusting
environment you know when you're playing
with so many new guys and you're trying
to implement offense defense day-to-day
and drill it and
you know you got guys coming off injury
and stuff like that just a realistic
viewpoint of being in the nba things
happen so
uh i think
you know when you're building
camaraderie and you're building a
franchise that you want to be successful
with and
um you know you really want to put your
your stamp your ego on us you know and
and you want to be
uh
doing the same things that you would
want to see from someone else you know
on your team that they have your back
you know so i think those things matter
and you know starting in october so 82
games and the playoffs they definitely
matter
and uh
in terms of my extension man i don't
really plan on going anywhere so
you know this is uh like i said this is
added motivation for our franchise to be
um at the top of the league uh for the
next few years and um you know i'm just
looking forward to the summer and just
building with
our guys here so
every just to follow up on that real
quickly you mentioned a few weeks ago
you don't want to leave kevin
you're going to be with him
do you see you guys together
for the long haul here
i mean
i think i kind of answered that you know
the last one in my last uh answer but
um when i say i'm here with kev i think
that it really entails us
um you know managing this franchise
together alongside joe and sean and
um just our group of family members that
we have in our locker room in our in our
organization you know so
um it's not just about me and kev i
don't want to make it just about that
we're cornerstones here but you know we
have been we have a few other guys that
are on contract and i think we just got
to make some moves this offseason really
talk about it and um really be
intentional about what we're building
and have some fun with it make it
enjoyable and um you know hopefully we
get to start from day one just as a
squad and as a family and we just really
worry about us you know sometimes i feel
like the noise on the external world or
outside noise could seep in and
um
you know i'm not i'm not the type of
person to allow that to happen so um as
we build together as a squad i just
think we need to be we need to be
tougher mentally
and uh just more honest about what we
want to accomplish and just stick to the
goal stick to the mission to your point
you guys went through so many things
off the floor
throughout the season
how much do you think all of those
events impacted the way the team played
on the floor
well again i think it was just really
heavy emotionally this season um
we all felt it uh i i felt like i was
letting the team down
uh at a point where i wasn't able to
play um you know we were trying to
exercise every option for me to play but
i never wanted to just be about me
and i think it became a distraction at
times and um you know as you see we just
had some drastic changes you know we
lost
[Music]
franchise player
and
we got a franchise player back but uh
you know we didn't get a chance to to
see him on the floor and um
there was no pressure for him either to
step on the floor with us either you
know what i mean like
ben's good we have been we have his back
he's going to be good for next year but
now we just we just turn the page and uh
look forward to what we're building as a
franchise and and really get tougher you
know because this is this is a league
that's getting younger it's getting more
athletic it's getting taller
you know and this is getting more
competitive and these young guys are
hungry out here
and you see it i could feel it so that's
why i said some added motivation you
know when
um you get swept like this
didn't necessarily play as well as i
would have liked
but now we just look
for the future as a team and what we can
accomplish for the next few years and i
get excited about that
kind of following up on all of that when
you look at the series that you had
against the celtics and they've got more
size right is that something that you
think you guys could stand to add more
size and just when you head into free
agency what what are some of the things
that you look at like okay that's what
we need to kind of get over the home
yeah we just we just have fun building
having that creative process you know
it's a co-management relationship you
know and um
[Music]
you just see that
the players have to jail
and you can't have these
little lulls of of just uncertainty you
know then we come in front of you and
you're asking us how the team's jailing
we're over here you know telling
everything's going well but
you know it just takes time and um
i think uh i'm just really putting a lot
of gratitude for the summer time for us
of just being intentional with who's in
our locker room and and how we're going
to be leading
and um
you know really just giving it our all
just leaving all
no stone unturned you know we don't have
to look back there's no question about
where i'm going and how this is going to
happen
i'm here with seven but also i'm here to
build a great team you know i would
i've scored you know some
averaged this many points done this many
things you know individually
been recognized for my greatness but at
this point in my career like i really
just want to be part of a great team and
and just dominate that way and
not really focus on any individual
accolades or achievements but just
really build something special so
i don't even want to be cliche with that
that takes time
um but yeah that's that's my focus going
into this summer it's just building with
my teammates and
you know just being there every day